this camp in the forest is what young
pakistani raheel staffer has called home
for three months
he shares his homemade tent with five
other men
there is my sleeping bag
this potato chili
water everything therefore you know
onion
this my food
every few days eight organizations pass
by
they distribute a bit of food and
clothing to the approximately 30 men
from pakistan in bangladesh
living in this camp near velika kladusa
a small town in bosnia herzegovina along
the croatian border
but beyond that all other supplies are
scarce says zahfer
who often has to saw his own firewood
temperatures frequently drop below zero
at this time of year
but he and the others want to hold out
in the cold and mud until their next
attempt to cross the border into croatia
and enter the eu i want to go you know
germania front front i want to go there
with friends
together and working in germany try it
maybe 10 15 time i go but please catch
they beat why you come in the crochet
why are you cause across water
you are illegal you don't have documents
why you coming across the border
that's too much try but inshallah one
day be successfully
no problem zafur hopes to find work in
germany
it was a daily struggle for survival in
his hometown of karachi pakistan
life here in the forest is hard says
zafur
but still better than in the lipa
refugee camp an hour's drive to the
south
where he previously stayed the lipa camp
has been in the international headlines
for weeks
first for being cleared out and then
because it burned down
these bunk beds are a lasting reminder
there are now new tents for the refugees
and migrants but many here say the
accommodation is now worse than before
this is a life for animals living place
here and we are suffering here that's
why we
doesn't gonna live here this is a not
suitable place for living during this
season the bosnian authorities have
faced harsh criticism in the wake of
these images
but in the nearby town of bihac the
mayor shushad faslich
places the blame on the bosnian
government and the
you know eu european union has spent
some so much money in in bosnia and
migrant crisis
but bihac has not received any
any euro we have been dealing alone with
our own money with our own resources
european union should treat
migrant crisis as a european problem as
a global problem
the bosnian public is also growing
increasingly wary of these migrants
fierce protests caused this refugee
shelter to close its doors a few months
ago
the eu wants refugees to move back in
here a nightmare scenario say residents
who have been protesting against it
every day
they said to us that we are asses we are
not racist three years
we're suffering and helping that people
they don't want to stay in bosnia
they just want to go to the border in
europe
and dear europe open the border
and take them but for many of the 8 000
or so refugees and migrants the chance
of being granted asylum in the eu
and therefore being allowed to stay is
very low
including for pakistanis like raheel's
offer
but that doesn't scare the 25 year old
who has no desire to stay in bosnia
and no intention of returning to
pakistan
this is not good what are you doing
there no have work
no have nothing europe have everything
they give camp is good every food is
good cloth is good everything
we work there no problem that's why we
want to go there you know
hey
as soon as it gets warmer rahil's offer
wants to make a new attempt to cross the
border into croatia
but for the time being he has no choice
but to stick it out here
in the mud rain and bitter cold